for years now I've been talking about
the difference between Democratic
socialists and Social Democrats and I
don't want to redo the entire analysis
again but to sort of like top line it
for you the real difference is that
Democratic socialists are socialists
where Social Democrats are not right the
democratic socialism is socialism in the
sense that it includes socializing the
means of production social democracy is
what sometimes called a blended economy
it's called well regulated capitalism
private ownership of businesses remains
but there's a very heavy focus on using
tax revenue for a strong social safety
net using progressive taxation to ensure
people don't get left behind that we
properly fund healthcare and education
and so on and Bernie Sanders has a long
history of calling himself Democratic
Socialist and he may well come from sort
of democratic socialist lines of thought
but Bernie's platform today is not a
democratic socialist platform
Bernie's platform in 2016 was not a
democratic socialist platform he is a
social democrat now I'm not criticizing
Bernie because he can't be a Democratic
Socialist because he shouldn't be a
Democratic Socialist he can be whatever
he wants to be but it is truly becoming
self-destructive for Bernie Sanders to
refer to himself as a Democratic
Socialist when he's not because it
allows the right-wing smear merchants
and the attacks on Bernie related to
Venezuela and Stalinist type communism
or Cuba or whatever even as a Democratic
Socialist those attacks would be stupid
and misguided but the the the reality is
that those are allowed to be more
successful by virtue of Bernie referring
to himself as a Democratic Socialist now
there are people who are going to hear
me say this and they'll write in and
they'll say you know David the terms
have become interchangeable Social
Democrat and Democratic socialists in
modern American politics it's sort of
the same thing this is really a semantic
disagreement semantics is exactly why
this matters right I agree with you
I'm saying there is a hang-up here about
socialism and communism these are
politically loaded terms nobody benefits
from this confusion and Bernie should be
saying I'm a social democrat in the
style of the Nordic countries and
Denmark and similar countries in the
style of the the Swedish social
democracy of the early 20th century for
example these are capitalist countries
that have decided we are going to use
the fruits of the economy not to allow
unfettered out-of-control inequality and
a shrinking middle class at the expense
of the super-rich becoming even
wealthier but these are capitalist
countries that have said we are going to
use the fruits of the economy to make
sure that we raise people's standard of
living that we provide health care to
everybody that we properly regulate
industry which does not have an
incentive to regulate itself that's the
Bernie platform right the the platform
is social democracy not democratic
socialism and the only defense of Bernie
calling himself a Democratic Socialist
is that the meaning of democratic
socialism has changed and that's not a
very good argument okay most people
don't know what socialism actually is
they don't know the difference between
socialism and communism they don't know
the difference between any of these
terms let's not make it easier for them
to muddy the waters by using the wrong
term or misunderstanding what it is that
Bernie Sanders is we have to contend
with the reality that we have
unfortunately uninformed or in most
cases poorly informed society in the
United States half the country doesn't
vote most people are totally unaware
about basic realities of this sort don't
make it easier for them to to
misunderstand what it is that bernie is
doing by using the wrong terms so here's
my request to you contact the Bernie
campaign tweet them go to their website
whatever tell them Bernie
stop saying Democratic Socialist say
social democrat I agree with the
platform of social democracy that's
Bernie's platform let
to use that term and if you disagree
with my analysis write to me and tell me
what's the upside of Bernie calling
himself a Democratic Socialist when he's
actually not espousing a democratic
socialist platform I'm actually open to
having my mind changed I posted on
Twitter earlier today at D Pakman what
are strong arguments for why Bernie
should call himself a Democratic
Socialist even though he's not the
argument that the meaning of the terms
has sort of changed or become muddled or
gray that's a bad argument I disagree
with that argument but if you have other
arguments to make I want to hear from
you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
support those who support the David
Pakman show and today that includes our
good friends over at BRD Bitcoin wallet
these guys are awesome and the BRD
bitcoin wallet is absolutely perfect for
anybody who's getting into Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency for the first time
because it was designed with simplicity
and ease of use in mind but you'll also
love it if you have experience with
Bitcoin it's an all-in-one app for iOS
and Android that lets you buy Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies using your
credit card lets you store everything on
the app for free you can trade and sell
cryptocurrency within the app and when
you use BRD wallet you're the only
person who has access to your Bitcoin
BRD doesn't store any of your personal
information you don't even have nor do
you need a username and password on the
platform it's all within an environment
that's virtually impossible to hack so
your cryptocurrency is safe extremely
easy to use
it's how I store my own Bitcoin I think
you'll be impressed with it too it's the
first-ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App
Store and now they have over two million
users from more than 170 countries BR DS
mission is to make buying selling and
storing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies simpler more efficient
and more secure and they've done an
awesome job check out my interview with
Aaron from the BRD team we had a really
interesting discussion about the state
of crypt
currency going forward you can also
download the BRD app for ios and android
i've put a link right underneath this
video